we're looking at the live shots at the
House of Commons as soon as quasi
quatane gets to his feet we'll go right
there and it looks like he is uh now so
let's take a listen in shall we and uh
Mr Speaker let me start directly
with the issue most worrying the British
people today the cost of energy people
will have seen the horrors of Putin's
illegal invasion of Ukraine they will
have heard reports that they're already
expensive energy bills could reach as
high as 6 500 pounds next year Mr
Speaker we were never going to let this
happen my right honorable friend the
Prime Minister has acted with great
speed to announce one of the most
significant interventions the British
state has ever made people need to know
that help is coming and help is indeed
coming we're taking three steps to
support families and businesses with the
cost of energy firstly to help
households the energy price guarantee
will limit the unit price that consumers
pay for electricity and gas this means
that for the next two years the typical
annual household bill will be 2 500
pounds for a typical household that is a
saving of at least a thousand pounds a
year based on current prices We are
continuing our existing plans to give
all households 400 pounds off bills this
winter so taken together Mr Speaker we
are cutting everyone's energy bills by
an expected 1 400 pounds this year and
millions of the most vulnerable
households will receive additional
payments taking their total savings this
year to two thousand two hundred pounds
secondly
as well as helping people we need to
support the businesses who employ them
the energy bill relief scheme will
reduce wholesale gas and electricity
prices for all UK businesses Charities
and the public sector such as schools
and hospitals this will provide a price
guarantee equivalent to the one provided
for households for all businesses across
the country
thirdly
Energy prices are extremely volatile
rising and falling erratically every
hour this creates real risks to energy
firms who are otherwise viable
businesses those firms help Supply the
essential energy needed by households
and businesses so to support the market
we are announcing the energy markets
financing scheme delivered with the bank
of England this scheme will provide a
hundred percent guarantee for commercial
Banks to offer emergency liquidity to
energy Traders Mr Speaker the consensus
amongst independent forecasters is that
the government's energy plan will reduce
Peak inflation by around five percentage
points it will reduce the cost of
servicing index link government debt and
lower wider cost of living pressures and
it will help millions of people and
businesses right across the country with
the cost of energy let no one doubt Mr
Speaker that during the worst energy
crisis in Generations this government is
on the side of the British people
the bank of England are taking further
steps to control inflation acting again
only yesterday and I can assure the
house that this government considers the
bank of England's Independence to be
sacrosanct and we remain closely
coordinated with the governor and myself
speaking twice a week
but Mr Speaker high energy costs are not
the only challenge confronting this
country growth is not as high as it
should be this has made it harder
to pay for public services
requiring taxes to rise in turn higher
taxes on Capital higher taxes on labor
have lowered Returns on investment and
work reducing economic incentives and
hampering growth still further
cycle has led to the tax burden being
forecast to reach the highest levels
since the late 1940s before before
before
even her late Majesty exceeded to the
throne we are determined Mr Speaker to
break that cycle we need a new approach
for a new era
our aim over the medium term is to reach
a trend rate of growth of 2.5 percent
and our plan Mr Speaker is to expand the
supply side of the economy through tax
incentives and reform that is how we
will deliver higher wages greater
opportunities and crucially Mr Speaker
fund Public Services now and into the
future that is how we will compete
successfully with Dynamic economies
around the world and that is how Mr
Speaker we will turn this vicious cycle
of stagnation into a virtuous cycle of
growth so as a government we will focus
on growth even where that means taking
difficult decisions now none of this is
going to happen overnight but today but
today we are publishing our growth plan
today we are publishing our growth plan
that sets out a new approach for this
new era built around three Central
priorities
reforming the supply side of the economy
maintaining a responsible approach to
Public Finance and cutting taxes to
boost growth
okay today
to the second lowest debt to GDP ratio
of any G7 country in due course we will
publish a medium-term fiscal plan
setting out our responsible fiscal
approach more fully including how we
plan to reduce debt as a percentage of
GDP over the medium term and the obr Mr
Speaker will publish a full economic and
fiscal forecast before the end of the
year with a second to follow in the New
Year fiscal responsibility remains
essential for economic confidence and it
is a path we are committed to
today we're publishing costings of all
the measures the government has taken
and those costings will be incorporated
into the obr's forecast in the usual way
the house should note that the estimated
costs of our energy plans are
particularly uncertain given volatile
Energy prices but based on recent prices
the total cost of the energy package for
the six months from October is expected
to be around 60 billion pounds we expect
the cost to come down as we negotiate
new long-term energy contracts with
suppliers and in the context of a global
energy crisis Mr Speaker it is entirely
appropriate for the government to use
our boring powers to fund temporary
measures in order to support families
and businesses that's exactly what we
did during the covid-19 pandemic a
sizable intervention was right then and
it is right now the price the heavy
price of inaction would have been far
greater than the cost of these schemes
Mr Speaker we're at the beginning of a
new era and as we contemplate and as we
contemplate
that's right that's right a new era a
new era
and as we contemplate and as we
contemplate this new era we recognize
we recognize Mr Speaker that there is
huge potential in our country we have
unbounded entrepreneurial drive we have
highly skilled people we have immense
Global presence in sectors like Finance
like life sciences technology and clean
energy but Mr Speaker there are too many
barriers for enterprise we need a new
approach to break them down and that
means reforming the supply side of our
economy
over the coming weeks my cabinet
colleagues will update the house on
every aspect of our ambitious agenda
those updates will cover the planning
system business regulations Child Care
immigration agricultural productivity
and digital infrastructure but Mr
Speaker we start this work today an
essential Foundation of growth is
infrastructure the roads Railways and
networks that carry people goods and
information all over our country today
our planning system for major
infrastructure is too slow and
fragmented the time it takes to get
consent for nationally significant
projects is getting slower not quicker
while while Mr Speaker our International
competitors Forge ahead we have to end
this we can announce that in the coming
months we will bring forward a new bill
to unpack and pick the complex Patchwork
of planning restrictions and EU derived
laws that constrain our growth
we will streamline a whole host of
Assessments of appraisals of
consultations endless duplications and
regulations we will also review the
government's business case process to
speed up the decision making
and today we are publishing a list of
infrastructure projects that will be
prioritized for acceleration in sectors
like transport energy and telecoms and
to increase housing Supply and enable
forthcoming planning reforms we will
also increase the disposal of surplus
government land to build new homes Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker we are getting out of
the way to get Britain building
[Applause]
one of the proudest achievements of our
conservative government is that
unemployment is at the lowest level for
nearly 50 years
but with more vacancies than unemployed
people to fill them we need to encourage
people to join the labor market we will
make work pay by reducing uh people's
benefits if they don't fulfill their job
search commitments we will provide extra
support for unemployed over 50s and will
ask around 120 000 more people on
Universal Credit to take active steps to
seek more and better paid work or face
having their benefits reduced
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker at such a critical
time for our economy it is simply
unacceptable it is simply unacceptable
that strike action is disrupting so many
lives
other European countries
other European countries have minimum
service levels to stop militant trade
unions closing down transport networks
so we will do the same
and we will go further we will legislate
to require unions to put pay offers to a
member vote to ensure that strikes can
only be called once negotiations have
genuinely broken down
and of course Mr Speaker to drive growth
we need new sources of capital
investment to this end I can announce
that we will accelerate reforms to the
pension charge cap so that it will no
longer apply to well-designed
Performance fees this will unlock
pension fund investments into UK assets
and Innovative high growth businesses it
will benefit it will benefit Mr Speaker
Savers and increase growth and we will
provide up to 500 million pounds to
support new Innovative funds and attract
billions of additional pounds into UK
Science and Technology scale-ups now Mr
Speaker this brings me to the cap on
Bankers bonuses
a strong UK economy has always depended
on a strong financial services sector we
need Global Banks to create jobs here
invest here and pay taxes here in London
in London not in Paris not in Frankfurt
and not in New York all the bonus cap
did was to push up the basic salaries of
Bankers or drive activity outside Europe
it never cuts it never capped total
remuneration so let's not hear and sit
here and pretend otherwise it didn't
come uh uh total remuneration so as a
consequence of this Mr Speaker we are
going to get rid of it
and to reaffirm
[Applause]
and to reaffirm the UK status as the
world's Financial Services Center I will
set out an ambitious package of
regulatory reforms later in the Autumn
but Mr Speaker to support growth right
across the country we need to go further
with targeted action in local areas so
today I can announce the creation of new
investment zones we will liberalize
planning rules in specified agreed sites
releasing land and accelerating
development and Mr Speaker we will cut
taxes for businesses in designated tax
sites for 10 years there will be
Accelerated Tax reliefs for structures
and buildings and a hundred percent tax
relief on qualifying investments in
plants and Machinery on purchases of
land and buildings for commercial or new
residential development there will be no
stamp duty to pay whatsoever on newly
occupied business premises there will be
no business rates to pay whatsoever and
if a business hires a new employee in
the tax site then on the first fifty
thousand pounds they earn the employer
will pay no National Insurance
whatsoever
that is an unprecedented set of tax
incentives for business Mr Speaker to
invest to build and to create jobs right
across the country I can confirm to the
house that we're in early discussions
with nearly 40 places like teas Valley
the West Midlands Norfolk and the west
of England to establish investment zones
and will work with the developed
administrations and local Partners to
make sure that Scotland Wales and
Northern Ireland will also benefit if
they are willing to do so if we really
if we really want to level up Mr Speaker
if we really want to level up Mr Speaker
we have to unleash the power of the
private sector
and now Mr speaker
now Mr Speaker we come we come to tax
Central to solving the riddle of growth
the tax system is not simply about
raising revenue for public services
vitally important though that is tax
determines the incentives across our
whole economy and we believe that high
taxes reduce incentives to work they
deter investment and they hinder
Enterprise as my right honorable friend
the Prime Minister has said we will
review the tax system to make it simpler
more Dynamic and fairer for families and
we're taking that first step today
Mr Speaker the interest of businesses
are not separate from the interests of
individuals and families in fact it is
businesses that employ most people in
this country it is businesses that
invest in the products and services we
rely on every additional tax on business
is ultimately passed through to families
through higher prices lower pay or lower
Returns on savings so I can therefore
confirm that next year's planned
increase in cooperation tax will be
canceled the corporation tax rate will
not rise to 25 it will remain at 19 and
we will have the lowest rate of
corporation tax in the G20 this will
plow almost 19 billion pounds a year
back into the economy that's 19 billion
pounds for businesses to reinvest create
jobs raise wages or pay the dividends
that support our pensions I've already
taken steps elsewhere in this statement
to support financial services so the
bank surcharge will remain at eight
percent
but Mr Speaker we will do more to
encourage private investment the annual
investment allowance which gives 100 tax
relief on investments in plant and
Machinery will not fall to 200 000
pounds as planned it will remain at a
million pounds and it will do so
permanently our duty our Duty Mr Speaker
is to make the UK one of the most
competitive economies in the world and
we are delivering we will deliver on
this Mr Speaker we want this country to
be an entrepreneurial share owning
democracy the Enterprise investment
scheme The Venture Capital trust we will
extend beyond 2025 the seed Enterprise
investment scheme company share option
plans we will increase the limits to
make them more generous crucial steps on
the road to making this a nation of
entrepreneurs for the tax system to
favor growth Mr Speaker it leads to be
much simpler I'm hugely grateful to the
office of tax simplification for
everything they have achieved since
2010.
but instead of a single arms length body
which is separate from the treasury and
hmrc we need to embed tax simplification
Into the Heart of government that is why
Mr Speaker I have decided to wind down
the office of tax liberation and
mandated every one of my tax officials
to focus on simplifying our tax base
to achieve a simpler system I will start
by removing unnecessary costs for
business firstly we will automatically
Sunset EU regulations by December 2023
requiring departments to review replace
or repeal retained EU law this will
reduce burdens on business improve
growth and restore the Primacy of UK
legislation Mr Speaker we can also
simplify the ir35 rules and we will
and practice reforms to off payroll
working have added unnecessary
complexity and cost for many businesses
so as promised by my right honorable
friend the Prime Minister we will repeal
the 2017 and 2021 reforms of course of
course we will continue to keep
compliance closely under review Mr
Speaker Britain welcomes millions of
tourists every year and I want our high
streets and airports our ports and our
shopping centers to feel the economic
benefit
so we have decided to introduce v80 free
shopping for overseas visitors we will
replace the old paper-based system with
a modern digital one and this will be in
place as soon as possible this is a
priority for our Great British retailers
so it is our priority too our drive to
modernize also extends
to alcohol duties
but I've listened to Industry concerns
about the ongoing reforms I will
therefore introduce an 18-month
transitional measure for wine Duty I
will also extend draft relief to cover
smaller to cover smaller kegs of 20
liters and above to help smaller
breweries
and at this difficult time we are not
going to let alcohol Duty rates rise in
line with RPI so I can announce that the
planned increases in the duty rates for
beer for cider for wine and for spirits
will all be canceled now Mr Speaker
now Mr speaker now Mr Speaker we come to
the question of personal taxation it is
an important principle that people
should keep more of the money they earn
and it is good policy Mr Speaker to
boost the incentives for work and
Enterprise yesterday we introduced a
bill that means the Health and Social
care Levy will not begin next year it
will be canceled
the increase in employer National
Insurance contributions and dividends
tax will be canceled and the interim
increase in the national insurance rate
brought in for this tax year will also
be canceled and this cap this
this will take effect from the
Earth November the 6th reversing the
levy delivers a tax cut for 28 million
people Mr Speaker worth on average
330 pounds every year a tax cut for
nearly a million businesses and I can
confirm the additional funding for the
NHS and social care services will be
maintained at the same level
yeah
yeah thank you
Mr Speaker
I have another measure
today's statement is about growth home
ownership is the most common route for
people to own an asset giving them a
stake in the success of our economy and
Society so support So to support growth
increase confidence and help families
aspiring to own their own home I could
announce that we are cutting stamp Duty
in the current system
there is no subjected to pay on the
first 125 000 pounds of a property's
value
we are doubling that to 250 000 pounds
currently pay no stamp Duty on the first
300 000 pounds we're increasing that
threshold as well to 425 000 pounds and
we're going to increase the value of the
property on which first-time buyers can
claim relief from five hundred thousand
pounds to 625
000 pounds the steps we've taken today
mean that 200 000 more people will be
taken out of paying snap Duty altogether
this is a permanent cut Mr Speaker to
stamp Duty effective from today I have
another measure Mr Speaker
I have another measure
High tax rates damage Britain's
competitiveness they reduced the
incentive to work to invest and to start
a business and the higher the tax the
more ways people seek to avoid them or
work elsewhere or simply work less
rather than putting their time and
effort to more creative and productive
ends take the additional rate of income
tax
45 percent it is currently higher than
the headline top rate in G7 countries
like the US and Italy and it is even
higher than social democracies like
Norway
but I'm not going to cut the additional
rate of tax today Mr Speaker
I'm going to abolish it all together
from April the 23rd we will have a
single higher rate of income tax of 40
this will simplify the tax system and
make Britain more competitive it'll
reward Enterprise and work it will
incentivize growth it'll benefit the
whole economy and the whole country and
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
after all this only returns us this only
returns us to the top rate we had for 20
years including the entire time the
opposition was lost in power
one month for one month and that's not
all I can announce today that we will
cut the basic rate of income tax to 19
pence in April 2023 one year earlier
that means a tax cut for over 31 million
people in just a few months time this
means that we will have one of the most
competitive and pro-growth income tax
systems in the world Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker for too long in this country
we've indulged in a fight over
redistribution yeah now we need to focus
on growth not just how we tax and spend
we won't apologize for managing the
economy in a way that increases
prosperity and living standards our
entire focus is on making Britain more
globally competitive not losing out to
our competitors abroad the Prime
Minister promised that we would be a tax
cutting government today we have cut
stamp Duty we've allowed businesses to
keep more of their own money to invest
to innovate and to grow we have cut
income tax and National Insurance
millions of workers we are securing up
our place in a fiercely competitive
global economy with lower rates of
cooperation tax and lower rates of
personal attacks we promise to
prioritize growth Mr Speaker we promised
a new approach for a new era we promised
to release the enormous potential of
this country our growth plan has
delivered all those promises and more MS
mend it to the house
yeah yeah order order before I call the
shutter Chancellor I informed The
Honorable and right honorable members
that at the end of questions on the
statement I will call the chancellor the
exchequer to move a provisional
collection of taxes motion copies of the
motion are being made available in the
vault's office I know called the shutter
Chancellor the exchequer Rachel Reeves
thank you Mr Speaker I would like to
welcome the right honorable gentleman to
his place can I thank the chancellor on
his comprehensive demolition of the
record of the last 12 years their record
their failure their vicious circle of
stagnation
chancellor has confirmed that the costs
of the energy price cap will be funded
by borrowing leaving the eye-watering
windfall profits of the energy Giants
untaxed the oil and gas producers will
be toasting the chancellor in the
boardrooms as we speak while working
people are left to pick up the bill
borrowing higher than it needs to be
just as interest rates rise and yet the
chancellor refuses to allow independent
economic forecasts to be published which
would show the impact of this borrowing
on our public finances on growth and on
inflation it is a budget without figures
a menu without prices speaker what has
the chancellor got to hide
this statement is an admission of 12
Years of economic failure
and now he here we are
one last throw of the dice one last
claim that these ministers will be
different
for chopping and changing all the chaos
and confusion the has been one person
one person there throughout
the Prime Minister she's been a minister
for a decade and defended every single
economic decision so when the Prime
Minister says she wants to break free
from the past what she really means to
say is that she wants to break free from
her own failed records
because where have the last 12 years
left us lower growth lower investment
lower productivity and today we learn
that we have the lowest consumer
confidence since records began the only
things that are going up are inflation
interest rates and bankers bonuses
[Applause]
I'm borrowing I'm borrowing as as the
Tories become more and more detached
from reality millions of people
millions of our constituents are lying
awake at night worried about how they're
going to make ends meet
labor won the arguments that action on
energy bills was necessary but the
question is the question is
who pays the energy producers who have
profited so much from the rises in
prices should make a contribution
but when the country asked who should
fit the bill for their energy rescue
package the conservatives responded you
the British people
instead of standing up for working
people the conservatives chose to Shield
the gigantic win for profits of the
energy Giants leaving 10 tens of
billions of pounds on the table and
pushing all of the costs onto
government's borrowing to be paid for by
current and future taxpayers the Prime
Minister and Chancellor have no regard
for taxpayers interests or for the
concerns of working people
it's not just the conservative party
it's not working for ordinary families
it is actively working against them
Mr Speaker we have had six so-called
plans for growth from the conservatives
since 2010. here they are Mr Speaker a
Litany of failure every single one of
them now
I do at least commend the chancellor on
having the ambition of achieving two and
a half percent growth a year the last
Labor government's rate of economic
growth
but to achieve that sort of growth and
for that sort of growth to be
sustainable you need a credible plan and
the truth is that this government does
not have one the Prime Minister and
Chancellor are like two desperate
gamblers in a casino chasing a losing
run the argument peddled by the
chancellor today isn't a great new idea
or a game changer as the minister said
as much as he'd like us to think so
what this plan adds up to is
corporation tax where it is today and
take National Insurance contributions
back to where they were in March some
new plan
and it's all based it's all based on an
outdated ideology that says if we simply
reward those who are already wealthy the
whole of society will benefit
they've decided to replace leveling up
with trickle down
as President Biden said this week he is
sick and tired of trickle-down economics
and he is right to be yeah it is
discredited it is inadequate and it will
not unleash the wave of investment that
we need
Mr Speaker it is not just those on this
side of the house who have these
concerns
the right honorable member for Surrey
Heath described the prime minister's
economic plans as taking a holiday from
reality
the right honorable member for Richmond
that was two chancellors ago was perhaps
foreign
he said we have tried having a low
corporation tax as a means of getting
business to invest but that it has not
worked
the new Chancellor and the new prime
minister used to agree with that indeed
they voted for it
labor supported it too members opposite
might have changed their minds but we
have not because the evidence shows that
low rates of corporation tax are not
what the best way to boost investment
and productivity and the Tories own
record shows that Britain has the lowest
headline rate of corporation tax in the
G7 but we also have the lowest rate of
business investments in the G7 that's
why labor would do what businesses are
actually asking for using targeted
investment allowances to boost
productivity and growth and scrapping
outdated and unfair business rates that
harm our high streets and small
businesses replacing them with a system
that's fit for the 21st century
and what about their other policies
let's take the so-called investment
zones again these are nothing new every
time they were tried all they have
achieved was moving growth around the
country not creating it
the best way out of the high tax lung
growth spiral that the conservatives
have created is to get the economy
firing on all cylinders in all parts of
the country it's going to take much more
much more than a stamp Duty cut to get
our country back on track and Home
Ownership back to the levels last seen
under a labor government
now these stamp Duty changes have been
tried before
last time the government did it a third
of the people who benefited were buying
a second home a third home or a buy to
let property is that really the best use
of taxpayers money when borrowing and
debt are already so high
and can the chancellor confirm today how
much of this stamp Duty cut will go to
those purchasing multiple properties
instead of stamp duties going up and
down like a yoyo we need to get building
we need to target support at first-time
buyers and tackle the issue of homes
being sold to overseas investors
the chancellor has made clear
who his priorities are today
not a plan for growth a plan to reward
the already wealthy a return to the
trickle-down of the past Back to the
Future not a brave New Era
the chancellor and prime minister
proclaimed in Britannia Unchained that
the British amongst the worst idlers in
the world and to prove that they mean it
instead of supporting working people
this government is cutting their rights
at work working people on the backbone
of Britain and they should be respected
not smeared at labor was always stand up
for their rights
Mr Speaker the chancellor has an effect
today admitted he has broken his own
fiscal rules
this is now the tenth time that the
Tories have broken their own fiscal
rules something I'm sure that the office
for Budget responsibility would have
confirmed if they had been allowed to
publish their forecasts today
Mr Speaker it is unprecedented to have a
fiscal statement of this scale with no
independent forecasts from the office
for Budget responsibility never has a
government borrowed so much and explains
so little
Economic Institutions matter yet this
government has undermined the bank of
England sacked the respected permanent
secretary at the treasury and silenced
the office for Budget responsibility
this is no way to build confidence this
is no way to build economic growth
Mr Speaker labor believes in wealth
creation we will always support
prize
[Music]
to grow to be successful and to
contribute to our country's prosperity
don't believe as a Chancellor and prime
minister do is that British workers are
idlers we understand that it is the
workers who turn up every day so make a
great product at a factory or deliver a
great service in the store who generates
growth it is the teachers giving the
young people the skills they need the
doctors and nurses keeping people well
the entrepreneur taking a personal risk
to start a new business
these are the people who generate growth
and they all deserve to share in it too
speaker this statement is more than a
clash of policies yeah
The Clash of ideas
two different ideas about how our
country prospers
few are a pensioner worried about the
cost of living a working family see your
mortgage rate going up a small business
whose costs are spiraling the
government's announcements today do
little to reassure them bigger bonuses
for Bankers huge profits for energy
Giants shamelessly shielded by Downing
Street and all the while ministers pile
the crushing weight of all of these
costs onto the backs of taxpayers
the value of sterling is that the value
of sterling has fallen we can see it
half his colleagues suspect it and
financial markets know it the verdict is
clear when it comes to the economy this
Tory leadership do not know what they
are doing the concern cannot solve the
cost of living crisis
being crisis and our country cannot
afford them any more
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker I was very
interested to hear uh the right
honorable ladies defense and I was very
curiously affected when she said
that neighbor believes in wealth
creation that was the biggest that was
the biggest fantasy I've ever heard you
cannot grow you cannot grow Mr Speaker
the economy if you keep taxing families
you cannot grow the economy you cannot
grow the economy if you see business as
the enemy yeah we have to reiterate very
clearly to our friends on the opposite
benches that you cannot tax your way to
prosperity
cannot help workers by increasing their
taxes and far from uh denigrating
British workers what our measures have
done what are what our measures have
done is they are relieving their
relieving burdens on our workers and our
people by energy intervening on Energy
prices and also relieving the burden of
Taxation we've got to unshackle uh the
creative energies of this country and
that's what we're 100 focused on doing
yeah stride
yeah Mr Speaker I welcome uh much in
this uh statement there is uh a great
deal that will help millions of families
and businesses up and down the country
but there is a vast void at the center
of the announcements that have been made
this morning and that is the lack of an
independent obr forecast and at a time
Mr Speaker when the markets are getting
Twitchy about government bonds when the
currency is under pressure now is the
time for transparency and making it very
clear that whatever tax cuts or
otherwise there may be they are done in
a fiscally responsible Manner and I have
to say to my right honorable friend that
he should have come forward with an obr
forecast and that we know as a committee
because of our correspondence with
Richard Hughes the head of the obr that
the obr was standing ready to come
forward with just such a forecast
and we further know because of that
correspondence so there is a forecast a
baseline forecast that the chancellor
has at the moment and would have been on
his desk when he first arrived in office
so could I now gently and respectfully
ask him to release that forecast to
provide transparency to the house to
provide a calmness to the markets and to
do it without any further delay thank
you I'd like to thank my right honorable
friend and I'd also like to gently and
respectfully remind him that in the
statement I committed in a in a very
categorical way to the obr coming up
with a forecast before before uh the end
of the calendar year it will be a full
forecast there won't be a baseline
forecast and it will fully score the
measures outlined in this great plan and
I'd be very happy to meet him in his com
in his committee uh at a time which is
convenient
I said Peace spokesperson Alison thulas
thank you Mr Speaker the chancellor
comes here today the sixth Chancellor in
seven years asking us to believe in the
things that he voted for and supported
just a few months ago were all fine at
the time but he completely reversed now
a new era but they've been in government
for 12 years he stretches credibility
Beyond Breaking Point saying that tax
cuts for the rich whopping bonuses for
the bankers and low corporation tax for
companies will somehow refloat magically
Britain's sinking economy he has no
evidence and this is no plan for growth
it is budget measures with no OVR
assessment ducking scrutiny time and
time again it is a plan Mr Speaker for
recession for debt on an unsustainable
trajectory and almost inevitable public
sector cuts to come actively choosing to
permanently cut taxes and spend
eye-watering sums to patch up a field
energy Market while inflation soars
interest it's our height and recession
blooms will not create growth it will
create economic chaos nothing he has
said today will provide any reassurance
and give hope to Ordinary People folks
struggling to get by in broke broken
Britain families unable to put food in
the table and Heat their homes punished
by the Tory benefit cap and the
two-child limit these policies are
driving up child poverty and the
chancellor should be strapping them not
the bankers bonus cap
indebted households already struggling
to pay their mortgages in debt a stamp
Duty cups is not going to help it's
going to overheat that housing market
even more Mr Speaker disabled people and
carers are terrified the electricity
will run out pensioners are scared to
turn on the heating the energy price
caps should not go up it's already too
high and people must get more help now
Asylum Seekers and people are stuck a
norly course to public funds are forced
to get by on a pittance and there is
nothing whatsoever for them from this
Chancellor
Mr Speaker Community organizations like
Glasgow Central mosque face additional
energy bills of hundreds of thousands of
pounds which is a charity they just
cannot afford people depend on community
organizations like the mosque and they
are being asked to be in the front line
this winter even with the six-month
reproval Energy prices these bills will
not go away with the chancellor have the
most close their elderly daycare service
or the counseling provision the mother
and toddler group the poverty reduction
work or the vaccination Center that's
been running in the Community Hall these
are very real choices communities are
already having to make the businesses
I've been listening to over the past
months are incredibly worried for the
future they were already facing severe
pressure through supply chain costs
input cost labor costs covenants and
brexit rules before Energy prices soared
now they don't know how they will
survive six months we'll go by in a
Flash and the question remains what then
what then from the chancellor companies
can't wash away where should we eat
these bills I want I wateringly
unaffordable contracts they are being
forced to sign right now what happens to
those businesses who just miss the
arbitrary cutoff and what have the
increase in standing charges which we
already know are disproportionately high
in Scotland Mr Speaker Scotland is an
energy rich country but we don't have
the power
Scotland's renewable sector is booming
but in off gas gradual Scotland
surrounded by the wind turbines
generating clean green energy people are
having to spend an absolute fortune in
heating oil and Argyle and beauty and
Angus the highlands and Ales and across
are rural communities households face
increases of over 230 percent in the
past two years alone the UK government's
offer of a hundred pounds is nothing
short of an insult as people turn to
credit cards to fill up their fuel tanks
the Scottish government is doing all in
its power to support people through this
crisis strengthening the safety net by
increasing the Scottish tail payment to
25 pounds a week doubling the fuel and
Security fund to 20 million pounds and
freezing rents because renters are also
facing pressures we have the highest
rates of the real living wage in
Scotland we've invested in tackling fuel
poverty and Energy Efficiency but we
could do so much more with more budget
and more Powers at the back of the blue
book today still no carbon capture and
storage for the northeast of Scotland a
game changer for Renewables in Scotland
where is that in the Chancellor's
requirements nowhere again
we should have growth by investing in
skills in net zero and productivity the
Chancellor's pounds will not do this
Mr Speaker people don't freeze to death
in our Nordic neighbors and people there
are not living in one of the most
unequal countries in the world and it's
only getting worse this right wing
Thatcher cosplaying shambles of a
government is making choices that we
will never feel the consequences of Mr
Speaker I beg of this Chancellor to
listen to those on the edge those who
are desperately looking right now to him
for a Lifeline but no one should have to
beg for a decent standard of living the
people of Scotland see a Scottish
government doing their best to mitigate
the worst but stymied by the Broken
politics of this Union and this economic
Madness we heard from the chancellor
today Scotland is looking for a
different path Mr Speaker Scotland needs
Independence
[Applause]
[Music]
what Scotland doesn't need is reheated
socialism from the SMP uh she mentions
energy and I was just I'm always
staggered when uh people on in her party
mention energy and they don't count on
its nuclear power nuclear power is a
great clean form of energy and it's and
while we speak about energy she will
know that we have indeed listened we
have uh implemented a a limit uh to
Energy prices my uh right honorable
friend the Prime Minister who's no
longer in her place made uh the the
engagement within two days of uh taking
office and it's something which I'm very
proud of and we've also extended it to
supporting businesses